jtf2 is canada's elite counter-terrorism
unit tasked with missions of the utmost
national importance including the
targeted killing of high-profile
individuals deemed to be terrorists and
performing hostage rescues
when senior members of the military
discovered at least three members of the
ultrasecretive unit were participating
in or supporting the convoy they
launched an investigation
documents obtained by global news show
the military was aware that members of
the unit were involved and expected the
story to snowball in the media two
members of jtf2 participated in the
protest and appear on social media
condemning vaccine mandates global news
has learned that a jtf2 officer was also
transferred out of the unit after it was
discovered he had donated to the convoy
financially online sources say the two
members who participated in the protest
have since been released from the
military in february major general steve
boivan the commander of the canadian
special operations forces told global
news if the allegations are accurate
this is wrong and it goes against
canadian armed forces values and ethics
cansofcom does not condone its members
supporting and or actively taking part
in causes that jeopardize the apolitical
imperative associated with their
functions members of jtf2 are not
allowed to participate in political
demonstrations or espouse
anti-government messages because they
must be prepared to respond to any order
the government of the day gives and
sources say that could have included a
response to the protest if national
security threats had materialized now
cansofcom is refusing to comment on why
the two members were released or
disclosed the findings of the
investigations in a statement the
command says upon learning of
allegations that members of the canadian
special operation forces command
supported the freedom protests in ottawa
investigations were initiated the
results of the investigation will not be
further discussed in order to respect
the privacy of the former canadian armed
forces members the pandemic put
tremendous stress on jtf2 like it did on
so much of canadian society and more
than a dozen sources with direct
knowledge of the unit say that the two
men in question who have since left the
military were highly decorated had
excellent service records and one was
even involved in that historic longest
sniper shot in iraq but things changed
when the vaccine mandates came in and it
created significant social splits in the
unit which have created questions about
culture and operational effectiveness
both of which many of the operators in
that unit say the command needs to
address
pharah
mercedes stevenson in ottawa thank you
mercedes